The joe rogan experience or was it a manner dangerous and that's why we have a
system called the Patriarchy took tact women.
Mike Michael Cost has a bit about a great system to protect women from the
dangers of men called Patriarchy and we threw it.
We throw it away because the colleges,
I think it's important to talk about patriarchy because I feel that young 20
year old women need their own Illuminati to talk about,
you know?
Yeah,
totally.
In their failures on what's going on.
It's,
yeah,
it's like it's Illuminati for girls.
Finally telling conspiracy theory,
patriarchy,
ask for the set definition.
There isn't one.
Is that as suspicious?
The same with racism.
There is one in the dictionary,
but I that's not the except to one.
Ask just any on my feminist.
What does it mean?
There's no,
well,
it can be whatever you want to be like.
It's,
it's,
it means you're my ex boyfriend named Jerry Click of mean girls is that
patriarchy are in a position of power,
right?
That's the patriarchy.
But men have been in the workplace for hundreds of years more than women is that
there's a real problem.
The idea,
the columns on it should be caught up.
But what about when you hear this shit where somebody goes,
when people wonder where all the female comedians?
I like,
no.
Uh,
he said that dude there,
people talking about it when it,
when Louie got shellacked by that fucked up article where people were saying
that shit about,
you know,
what,
how come there's not an equal number of female comedians to males?
Well,
because women are treated better in our society.
Yeah.
If there's enough damage,
amount of female Comedians,
you know,
women are being abused way more than ever because you don't get in his job from
a happy,
his job isn't about support.
It's you get last cause you fucked up.
So I hope there's not a lot of women in it that would mean they're being raped.
More does that.
But it is also,
it's just from a female perspective,
if a chick's funny,
it's harder because something happened to her.
They can't,
but they can't talk about certain things like,
no,
no man wants to see a woman on stage town politics stories or politic jokes.
If it's funny you say that,
but they did create a lot of the daily show.
Maybe you're right,
maybe you,
but most people in the audience for the woman who harder,
I won't rule out anything if I'll take,
I won't say any premises hacky,
just punch lines.
So if your premise is airline fucking peanuts,
that's fine.
Tell me what your punchline is.
Maybe your punchline justifies it,
right?
I don't,
I won't rule out any premise.
Premise is or hacky,
but people probably don't want to hear it,
but who you know,
it's like,
look,
if you can get people to listen to some shit that they basically don't want to
hear,
like,
oh great,
like this is from,
I used to do the black rooms when I started out.
I totally agree with you.
Yeah,
I'm totally in agreement with you.
We're not talking.
What are you drinking?
Caveman coffee.
We're not talking to you.
I feel wired is wicked wire from that 270 milligrams.
How many did you might go?
Well,
I just started sipping wine,
but I'm like,
I feel like I can one that's empty.
Did you black out and suck that one Justin?
I just drank one.
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
Nobody cares about those.
You like the use of like fungal.
Okay.
It's not used that often that it is in Jersey.
Go to the east coast.
Go to where those old school guineas landed on boats,
fucked each other on the rocks and made a bunch of them and they all stayed
there about phone.
Google.
What's the,
what's the Italian Horn like?
If you're Italian,
you always have had one of those
pig shows.
You're a moron.
I don't know.
I don't know where it came from.
We all had them in high school though.
It was like if you had a gold chain with a horn,
like wow,
look at stylish,
did not know that thing existed.
It's called the comma.
Cellos seen that sperm before,
but that's probably what it is.
Cold sperm,
little Horne or Horne let sometimes abbreviated to Como.
Isn't Italian amulet or talisman worn to protect against the evil eye
or Mala Ciccio and bad luck in general and historically to promote fertility and
virility.
That's the last thing we need to promote fertility and kids in high school
wearing those things.
So it is a sperm?
Yeah,
Neapolitan.
It's called Kumu Cielo or variance thereof.
What you're talking about?
My sperm.
That's crazy.
It is just,
it's just between your and your golden Jizz on your chest,
essentially.
Right?
The Golden Tj's or protect you from the evil eye.
You gave me the evil eye,
but I still got my not off.
Oh,
dad gave this to me.
The fucking evil eye over here.
Yeah.
What you're wearing it right where a pearl necklace with Lynn too.
Yeah,
it's foul.
Foul little amulet.
Imagine they talk those kids into wearing golden just around the neck and all
these years they thought,
hey,
that fucking evil.
I could suck my dick about that.
I'm going to go out.
I got a good amount of gold chains.
I got up.
Good solid fucking horn hand.
Look at that.
Can't,
Catholic priests probably give them to me it looks like calm.
Yeah.
It doesn't even look like a horn.
What kind of fucking Horn is that?
Where it's round on the top like a,
like a sperm head.
Horns aren't rounded at the top.
It's all rounded.
The top.
It looks like it's swimming up stream to the guys.
Mass is going into your mouth.
If you go back,
go back to those pictures of different ones.
Is there anyone that has a flat top that looks like a fucking horn?
No.
All of them are rounded at the top.
Like Jizz.
Those Italian horns,
they're all rounded at the top.
Like just,
this is insane.
I don't see any of them that look,
I go,
that's not an Italian horn at six that's the wrong one.
That's some,
that's some like Gucci Shit.
Like someone,
some designer got ahold of it and a new take on deal.
Italian horn.
It's all the rage everyone wears.
Everyone was,
yes,
I've got three on.
I can't believe people wear that shit.
They do.
They can't help themselves.
They grew up in those communities.
I did it too.
I wore one.
You're around a bunch of,
uh,
east coast Italian people.
They're all wearing it.
You're all wearing it.
It's like,
God,
you got yet Italian horn.
And when I say,
when I saw the guy that had it on,
he took,
I got,
yeah,
I got in and kissed it.
He kissed the ges.
It's just my good luck,
judge.
God bless you.
What saint who should be Saint Peter,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
I mean,
it's gotta be which ones attached to it.
That's like weird.
Like there's always affiliations,
like certain saints are attached to certain,
you know,
the fucking ridiculous.
Wow.
This,
what year was this,
Dear God,
I don't remember.
I've been having so much on it or whatever.
Yeah,
no,
you're great.
For a guy who's been hit in the head as many as you,
well,
I never had a concussion.
I will say that we must have never had a concussion.
Really?
Nope.
But what is a concussion?
Concussion is like,
well,
they check your pupils.
They're not dialing correctly.
None of them.
No concussions and all,
all that hard sparring.
Nope.
Never.
I find that hard to believe that he never got hit with a shot that they didn't
see coming.
And I think that's the difference.
Nope.
Wow.
Besides one time in a huge fight where a dude hit me in the side of the head
with a brick and I saw it last second,
I at least rolled with it.
And that didn't give you a concussion?
He,
I,
he uh,
it was a huge bro.
It was hip hop night at the nightclub I was bouncing at.
Oh,
sounds like fun.
And,
and,
and the Illinois gangbangers and the Iowa gangbangers started going at it and I
tried breaking it up and they all attacked me,
right.
Jesus.
So that's when I,
everybody was wearing,
it was wintertime.
So I was choking people.
A guy got me in a headlock and I was grabbing people by their coat lapels and I
hit my head in between his head and his head and I'd choke him unconscious.
I'd find a new coat and I was working my way backwards out the front door and
finally snuck out of the headlock,
put him in a rear choke,
went backwards off the door.
He went limp.
I dropped him.
And then as I turned to get out into the street,
cause there was cops everywhere at that point.
There's dogs,
there's,
it's a snow storm.
Last second,
I see this coming at the side of my head and I duck in,
it bounces off my head and this dude goes,
yeah,
like I was going to go down and I turned and I looked at him and rifled and with
the right hand and knocked him out.
And then the next thing you know there's just dogs diving into the crowd.
It was a good one.
And that was a fun one.
Dogs,
that's not good.
No.
Yeah,
the dogs work day work.
They work real well.
It's not good because they don't know who the fuck they're biting.
They might bite you.
They might bite the bad guys.
I mean,
who the fuck dogs don't know who the bouncer is?
Clear crowd out real quick.
Fuck.
Yeah,
they do.
Yeah.
After you've donate and you have to eat on the workout and stuff.
The children,
yeah.
You just feel loose and he feel amazing.
He's brilliant every Wednesday morning and I don't want to go,
I'll fucking tell you the truth.
I'm driving down that so now it away from me.
I'm thinking,
fuck this,
and then I get there and it's just,
it's just a very,
very special with illegal is weed and England.
I'm not into it.
Me,
listen bro,
take two solid hits and then go to yoga clinic.
It's all solid hits up behind in Rebecca myself or I'm telling you it's not
familiar to see American.
We get ahold of some of this California Shit.
Yeah.
Orbit serious two hits and then go to a yoga class.
It's like you're on a journey.
You're like,
you get out of their hour and a half late,
it's perfect cause an hour and a half into the sweating,
the pots worn off and you'll like you come back down and put in the middle of
it.
You feel like the world's going to end any second now in the middle of the
class,
like there's no way this can be sustainable.
There's no way I'm not going to survive.
Did the whole way.
You just think about everything that's going on in Tracy.
Get on with Joe.
We're like a house on fire.
Yeah,
that's been my dad
had not me.
I can't do it.
I don't agree with me.
I love it for Yoga.
Small.
My favorite things ever take two hits and go to yoga class.
I think it's when you stone,
you can't not be on stone quick.
He just like,
Oh shit.
No,
there's no wearing off quick.
Yeah,
caffeine helps a little bit.
I remember Jordan give me a drop of cannabis.
I'll be fine.
I like Mel it into,
we saw for for about six hours and I couldn't move and I'm thinking I'm dead.
I'm Sam,
I'm doing it.
Yeah.
Last time I was here high at some and I add some cannabis oil and I was sat
there watching TV and then I was like,
fucking hell,
that was mine.
And then you got the remote control from the TV and this guy was gotten a low
and it turned him over and I went,
Huh.
To me fucking self.
And then I knew for no,
it's not for you.
This
okay.